Facebook announced they will add a
dislike button to their site now they've
had a like button for years but now
people will also be able to show their
disapproval well I'm sorry but to me we
need more choices than just like or
dislike don't we that's not enough yeah
not everything is so black and white so
I think Facebook should have a lot more
options options such as like this hate
myself for this one I drank 10 beers and
don't remember liking this merger
goggles how about this one your baby is
not as cute as you seem to think it
I like this one 70% offended 30% of
[Applause]
how about this I like this and 117 of
your other pose because I'm alone at
this party and I'm trying to look busy
there's this one I like that you're
remembering your dear departed
grandparent but dislike that he or she
has passed away and I'm glad that it's
upsetting your sister because I hate her
does this one sorry I was doing that
thing where I sometimes click on boobs
in a photo to pretend I'm touching them
and finally like that you're having fun
at the beach dislike that I'm at a bus
stop in the snow
you